[Music]
las vegas firefighters gearing up for
one of the busiest weeks of the year
as the fourth of july holiday right
around the corner that means the use of
fireworks will be popular
all across the valley madison kimbrough
has the details on this year's
safe and sane fireworks hey sasha for
those that may not know safe and sane
fireworks have been tested and approved
by our city's fire department
to only be used during this one week of
celebration for the fourth of july
holiday
at all other times of the year safe and
sane fireworks are illegal as well as
any other type of fireworks that pop
off in the air the goal is for people to
buy these safe and sane fireworks and
use them responsibly
that means they should be used on a flat
firm surface such as the ground or
driveway
stay away from bushes grass or trees
always have a bucket of water and or
garden hose available for use in case of
a fire
and after the firework has been used it
should be picked up with a shovel
dropped into a bucket of water and then
soaked for several hours before being
put in the trash
tim cemanski with las vegas fire and
rescue explains the typical situation he
sees with people using fireworks this
time of year
what we commonly see is people sitting
in a cul-de-sac
and there might be a bunch of lawn
chairs around in a circle and
the people let the kids pick out which
one that they want
next and everybody's watching it
together that's probably the best way to
do it
another reminder keep vehicles in the
garage and all windows shut
as for our pets this is one of the
hardest times with the loud sounds and
vibrations
causing a lot of anxiety for them so
it's important we protect them by
keeping them indoors
and if you need to report illegal
fireworks you can use the website on
your screen that's i spyfireworks.com
only call 911 if someone is injured by
fireworks
reporting from las vegas madison
kimbrough 8 news now
and remember fireworks no matter what
kind are illegal on streets
in any parks and on school district
properties